if there were no editors in the world of
movies each of the nominated films would
be six hours long and the multiplex
would go out of business not only that
if there were no editors Julian and I
would not know when to stop talking
about this award nominees for
achievement in film editing are danielle
Rezende for City of God Walter Murch for
Cold Mountain
Jamie Selkirk for the Lord of the Rings
The Return of the King Lee Smith for
Master and Commander the far side of the
world
William Goldenberg for Seabiscuit and
the Oscar goes to James Selkirk for the
lure the ring for McCain
this is the first Academy Award AB
nomination for Jamie South Korea
there's a certainly a great honor thank
you to the Academy
thank you Peter and Fran give me the
opportunity it's fantastically involved
such a fantastic production since the
new line for putting up the cash to get
it going on the start started of the
trilogy thank you to my lovely wife Ann
for and my two boys Damon and Brad
they've been really supportive over the
last six years on this job and thank you
to all my great editing team you know
they actually are always people get left
behind and they actually a really
fantastic team they especially any
Collins and Jen Horvath and Peter Scott
Ginny bio and Joe priest
marquel thorn brass and Ian and Michelle
Dave and Heather they're all fantastic
team thank you very much
do you know that people are moving to
New Zealand just to be thanked